I love that you're inspired by sort of
sci-fi mood and also video game music
which I think is really cool because I
didn't ever think of video game music as
being sort of a genre or an inspiration
of course I grew up at a time when video
game music was just
[Laughter]
really early game yeah yeah like Ms
Pac-Man was like
oh
I was getting a lot of disappointing
noises because I wasn't good
try loser
that was your inner monologue oh that
wasn't even come to think of it I wasn't
playing a game that was just inner
monologue is just missed Pac-Man yeah
yeah that's why I've never been able to
be intimate with anyone
oh I really like you let's get down yeah
yeah
what Miss Pac-Man get out of my head
trying to get it on
this is such a stupid interview I
apologize you're such a talented person
I'm sorry you deserve better you do
deserve a real interviewer but recently
my son who's 17 started listening to all
this music and I said where does this
come from and he said it comes it's
gaming music but I was listening to it
and it's really good yeah what did you
start to notice was this something that
was always happening where you're
noticing different sounds that you liked
I guess so I mean I I was such an indoor
kid that I I just really enjoyed playing
video games and and was gifted like a
Super Nintendo when I was was five and I
always really enjoyed it and I think
it's really
um I'm gonna do a really bad job of
expressing this but I I think it's a
really interesting art form to interact
with because it there are games that
like sort of force you to make these
kind of like moral decisions and it's
like the only time that you're like
actively a part of like the medium in
that way that makes you kind of like
question your morality so for instance
there's this game called stardew Valley
have you heard of it it's like a farming
game and I think it's really interesting
something that like you can play games
that like uh have you like kill some
someone which you would never do in real
life but there is like a there's a thing
called JoJo March where it's like the
corporation and you can choose whether
or not you want to like go to the local
um seed
he's going to the local seed shop or
like go to a cheaper Corporation and
somehow like I've never gone to the
corporation like in the game and and
because that's like crossing a moral
line within the game but you can like in
other games you like stab someone and
it's it's fine but I think it's really
interesting to like interact with them
but it's interesting that I mean I find
it fascinating that games are getting so
sophisticated that you're making moral
choices and what's really interesting is
like first person shooter games you're
basically killing people left and right
but somehow we've been
inculcated that there's this it's not
real yeah you know it's not real and I
have there are certain things that are
like more triggering than others like I
think it was my my husband was playing
like Red Dead Redemption or something or
like some game where like you had oh uh
if you know the game chime in blame
maybe it's it's like it's not Skyrim but
it's like a similar game to that and
like he had to like kill a couple of
like dogs that were like attacking him
or whatever and for some reason like all
the people that he had to like fight was
okay but like when you you hit the dog
and it makes the sound it's like there's
something like really oh I I completely
understand I was watching a movie last
week and people are getting humans are
getting off left and right and then
someone like kicked a small bear yeah
and the Bear Went like and I I couldn't
I left the room I couldn't handle it
yeah I think that that's really
interesting I think there's a like a
Bartle me short story called um like the
gerbil and it's all of these like
terrible things happen in the class like
you know first it's like it's a gerbil
dies and then it's like a kid like falls
off of you know a play thing or whatever
and then they get a puppy and when the
puppy dies that's the moment like that
really right that's like the height of
uh tragedy not like this like a child
that fell in this yeah the kids suck you
know
I mean they do they're just such an
I
like my chocolate milk
you know
applaud when a child Falls
this is our last podcast this is a
successful podcast and you're a very
lovely talented person you've done
nothing wrong but somehow you've brought
it out oh yeah I'm sorry it's your fault
it feels to me like when I listen to
your music one of the things and I think
I even heard you say this that you like
this kind of Heroes versus Villains
dichotomy between good evil but how the
line is blurred and I always find that
fascinating because I love movies
occasionally I'll love a movie where
there's you know you watch die hard and
you know who the good guy is and the bad
guy is Hans Gruber and there's no
mistaking that but I'm more drawn to the
movies that I think have more of a
European event where
and absolutely it's interesting there
are people who are seem like the bad guy
and people who seem like the good guy
but the lines get blurred and you feel
like everybody's just trying to do their
own thing and and Havoc ensues I mean I
think that's like the purpose of art
really is to just like find humanity and
uh and and people you know I mean I
think my favorite shows are shows like
The Sopranos are like where you know
you're you're rooting you feel
conflicted because you're rooting for a
murder and I think it puts everything
into perspective you know I'm like
online you must have watched Sopranos on
the second go around right because he
seemed or no or you seem young to have
watched The Sopranos I remember when it
was coming out like my parents would
like I I think I wonder how old I was I
feel like I was definitely too young to
watch The Sopranos but my parents like
loved the show so much and I remember
like getting sent out of the room every
time like bada bing scene okay yeah but
yeah I mean I've rewatched it many times
since and and I feel like that's that
element of that show and I feel the same
way about Game of Thrones too where
you're just like I I love like being
manipulated to like hate someone in the
and then in the next scene like kind of
like really fall for them and I think
that that's what great art should do
what's funny you say that because I just
rewatched all The Sopranos
I made it a mission and I watched all of
them in like a month there's a terrific
book about The Sopranos by two writers I
think from the Star Ledger I want to say
and it's just a great essay about each
episode so I would watch the episode
then
then read this essay and I just got so
much meaning out of what re-watching it
and I'm just starting to my son's never
seen Game of Thrones so we're just
starting to watch it although that's
difficult because there's full-on crazy
nude sex yeah sometimes and when you're
a dad sitting in the room with your son
both of us want to die yeah yeah both of
us just want to make our hearts stop
through sheer force of will and die
because it's not you can't even pretend
it's not happening and and you're not
like oh this is cool sex I'm cool talk
you know about oh
you know in the sixth sense you knew a
ghost was in the room because they could
see their breath when I'm watching
television and sex is and I'm anyone
else is in the room and sex is
graphically depicted suddenly I can see
my breath
Suddenly It's like this Vapor coming out
of my mouth
and it always happens just beforehand I
know it's coming and then sure enough
slang
you know
that is the worst sound
actual scene I've ever heard of you
don't think that's an accurate flange
we have a professional I know
musicologist artist here who will vouch
that that is the exact way it sounds
you're gonna rip me off too I know in
your next album you're gonna have a huge
hit with swing
and the Grammy for Best single
Japanese breakfast with swangs
like I know I'm gonna get mentioned nope
you mentioned all your friends oh you're
cool Pals and not one word for me